les opportunités pour berner les
internautes relève souvent de concept
assez simples comme des faux billets de
banque
existe aussi des faux sites web
l'exemple des sites web de nouvelles
clown et mérite qu'on s'y attarde
qu'est ce que tu penses que ça fait
vraiment ce que je peux voir je regarde
faire rapidement le c'est vraiment la
facture visuelle du site officiel de cnn
sur deux raisons ouais c'est un faux
c'est quelque chose qu'on voit de plus
en plus des gens kribi fossiles qui
reprennent la facture visuelle des
médias reconnus donc ceci ce n'est
absolument pas cnn mais si identique au
site de cnn
autre exemple un autre exemple si un
autre un autre site kicker que pied la
fonction visuelle de sib ici ouais ils
ont bien français messi messi mais ça
ressemble quand même beaucoup à l'ancien
facture visuelle de subi 6 même chose
pour respirer site de nouvelles
sportives celui là il suffit pas bien
fait c'est absolument identique au site
de deux aspirent on en voit aussi
parfois sur les réseaux sociaux donc ça
avait circulé l'année dernière que la
collègue pascale nadeau
donc c est écrit donné un nouvel au
canada un homme d'affaires fou donne de
l'argent et on donne l'impression que si
un article du téléjournal
donc on essaye clairement d'aller
chercher la crédibilité des médias en
question pour aller chercher des déclics
c'est ça parce que c'est ça qu'on
utilise la crédibilité pour qu'à des
fins de revenus au paiement mais
exactement donc la plupart de ces faux
site le c'est de la publicité qu'en fit
donc le but c'est qu'on lit là qu on lit
l'article et que ça nous envoie un
magasin en ligne pour qu'on achète un
produit ou un service donc dans le cas
de ce faux article
oui peu importe où on clique sur le site
semaine n'y a pas d'article n'y a pas
d'autres défauts c'est vrai c'est ok
donc vraiment le but c'est qu'on pense
que c'est un reportage de cnn
on s'intéresse à ce que c'est et puis
non on s'inscrit à ce casino en ligne
donc c'est vraiment si des stratagèmes
on utilise une force nouvelle pour
envoyer des gens pour qu'ils achètent
des produits des services et si
énormément payant pour les gens qui
créent ces fossés salon vient
chatouiller finalement l'instinct
curiosité de l'être humain
comment on fait pour déceler pour
contourner ce genre de cette laisse que
des indices des trucs tu peux tout à
fait le premier conseil c'est super 5
tout à regarder la barre d'adressé donc
quand on est sur le vrai cette
discipline cia spin.com l'adresse web
sur cette langue c'était revolution
break.com qui n'est pas le citer
cependant qu'on voit que c'est selon
deuxièmement c'est simple si tu laisses
sont créés pour envoyer des gens voir en
magasin en ligne donc peu importe où on
clique sur ce samedi en vo magasins donc
ce salaire de nous envoyer vers un autre
article du même site mais quand on
clique dessus ça nous envoie au magasin
est donc si on clique ici pour la page
principale ça me rend vos magasins donc
tous les liens mènent aux mêmes magasins
dont on se rend compte assez vite je
sais pas en réussite de me dire c'est
tout simplement une copie bref comme
tout joueur comme dit le vieil adage le
nerf de la guerre c'est l'argent
[Musique]